Chris Pratt and cap - warts and [ __ ]
PD a Seth Rogen is Grammy hopeful with
Beyonce and Donald Glover plus a
Bachelor alums face their fears you guys
can you imagine if Chris Pratt started
calling Arnold Schwarzenegger dad
crazier things have happened but it
could be heading that direction because
perhaps relationship with Arnold's
daughter Catherine is heating up a
couple shared a sweet kiss in the middle
of their hangout in Los Angeles on
Sunday the smooch happened after the
attended church with Chris's son Jack
now after sealing their last date with
the kiss the source tells et Chris Pratt
and captain Schwarzenegger have gotten
serious quickly the two went from
casually dating to spending much more
time together so with their couple named
beat Pratt's a [ __ ] okay working title
but one sure sign they are getting
serious catherine has been spending some
quality time with jack something that we
learned firsthand is important to Chris
when do you think your son looks up to
you most is it when you're fishing is it
when you're working what is I think my
love language is quality time so when we
can sit down and just be together and
spend time together with one another
just me and him that's that's probably
when I'm the happiest and when he looks
up to me the most
we're told Catherine's mom helped set
them up and that they have introduced
one another to their family and friends
and have been almost inseparable when
they are free which makes sense because
between being and the spotlight and
about Christians they actually have a
few things in common but I want to know
what do you guys think of them together
on a scale from one to ten being John
Legend and Chrissy Teigen how cute are
they I'm checking your comments so let's
see it I've been moving on to Beyonce
because there is actually a few things
to talk about with her first of all her
braids made a comeback last night at on
the run two in Philly and don't roll
your eyes at me because that braid
literally has its own hairography and
its iconic don't at me anyway but
apparently B is also set to break some
barriers in the fashion world for that
team where I've got my fellow beehive
member our very own Courtney tez know
she's buzzing about that no you're not I
loved it but Beyonce runs the world okay
but get this Queen B is reportedly not
going to be on the cover of Vogue
coveted September issue but is using her
power and influence to hire the mags
first black cover photographer it's the
first time and get this 126 years I'm
like blown away by the crazy
according to Huffington Post vogue
editor-in-chief Anna Wintour has given
Beyonce unprecedented control over the
photos the captions she'll write herself
I mean it's everything I mean obviously
this has us all buzzed it but especially
the fact that it's taking this long for
a black photographer to be able to shoot
the cover right but I think it's a step
in the right door 100 kudos to you bean
we cannot wait to see that cover well we
do something to hold us over until then
which is Rihanna who's on the cover of
British Vogue September cover and she is
service looks funny all right we love
those style icons Rihanna Beyonce I'm
just obsessed but well how about Beyonce
in this upcoming Lion King live-action
area I know you just chatted with one of
her cosa it was such a good chat you
guys i sat down with seth rogen who was
the voice of Pumbaa and he dished all
about the all-star cast of the upcoming
Disney movie it's great I mean it's it's
amazing for many reasons one is because
I am a big fan of liking too because
it's like the most expensive movie I'll
ever have anything to do throwing the
Jon Favreau the director I've known
since I was 18 and is a very close
friend of mine and so it's again always
exciting when you get to work with
people that you know well yeah we're
good friends and so yeah I mean overall
it's it's surreal it'll be weird how
surreal would it be if you want a Grammy
Beyonce and all the Glover I mean it's
not we can't wait for this for Robbo I
interviewed you know the voice of young
Simba JD McCreary earlier this year he's
seen a little bit a bit of it and he say
it's going to be amazing so oh my god we
can't wait I can't believe 2019 I know I
know it'll be worth the wait though
alright thanks Courtney thank you guys
before we sign off tonight some of your
favorite bachelor alums are being
being put through a different kinda
ringer as contestant on Celebrity Fear
Factor and I was on the set and let's
just say they scared all right three two
one this is next-level everything I've
been through on bachelor and
bachelorette I see I think today it kind
of topped it our strategy is do not
freak out how would you compare the
experience which is more terrifying
well I'm terrified of love so that was
scary for me too but this is just even
more terrifying I felt like I was in a
torture chamber yep this was just how
the teams who play for $50,000 to a
charity of their choice include Alexis
Waters and her sister Nicole Korean
elympios and BFF Gigi
Vanessa Grimaldi and Daniel Maltby Plus
former Bachelorette Rachel Lindsay and
fiance Brian Alva solo I don't know
what's wrong with us
like I feel like we just keep
challenging ourselves we're like oh that
week we passed that test let's do
something else crazy every target they
hit it'll turn off a fire bar you can
see them in action on Celebrity Fear
Factor tonight on MTV and catch more of
my interviews with them on e t
online.com and i'll see you guys
tomorrow
you